they begin life as ghosts gently
coursing through a solitary existence
but slowly their gentility turns to rage
they grow larger and larger curling and
twisting and desperately reaching down
from the sky in what began as an
invisible shade his turn
into a monster
tornadoes are powerful spinning columns
of air that stretch from the ground to
the clouds most are relatively weak but
the few that grow into large events are
extremely violent and caused immense
destruction tornadoes occur on six of
the seven continents the country with
the most tornadoes based on land size is
the United Kingdom with an average of
about 33 tornadoes reported each year
but the country with the greatest
overall number of tornadoes and the most
intense is the United States with over
1,000 reported annually tornadoes no
matter where they occur are classified
as either supercell tornadoes which form
within super cells the most powerful
class of thunderstorms or non supercell
tornadoes which are smaller and weaker
and form within non supercell storms
there are many theories surrounding the
formation of tornadoes one key component
they share is the presence of both high
and low pressure air in a given space
air particles from the area of high
pressure move toward an area of low
pressure a movement that creates wind
non supercell tornadoes such as water
spouts and land spouts begin when cool
high-pressure air and warm low-pressure
air are present particularly near ground
level as air particles move horizontally
from the high pressure area to the low
pressure area wind begins to pick up
winds blowing at different speeds and in
different directions and altitudes begin
to blow cyclically in the case of non
supercell tornadoes they turn into an
upright spinning vortex
but to create supercell tornados the
circumstances are slightly different
violent supercell storms draw warm
low-pressure air up to a higher altitude
leaving behind cool high-pressure air
near the ground air particles attempting
to bring the two levels of air pressure
into balance creates wind that blows
vertically the wind increases and starts
to blow in a cyclical fashion creating a
pipe of wind that rolls along the ground
in both cases an upward current of wind
called an updraft provides the final
ingredient for creating a tornado in a
budding non supercell tornado an updraft
stretches its vertical vortex until it
reaches the clouds to create a supercell
tornado an updraft lifts the rolling
pipe of wind upward until it stands
upright then it pulls condensation from
the skies and into the spinning vortex
as soon as the vortices supercell or non
supercell connect the ground to the
clouds they are officially classified as
tornadoes all tornadoes are rated based
on a system called the Enhanced Fujita
scale the Enhanced Fujita or EF scale
classifies tornadoes from a rating of EF
0 to EF 5 the rating is based on a
number of factors such as the damage of
tornado causes and the Doppler radar
estimates of its wind speeds EF 0
tornadoes are the weakest with wind
speeds between 65 to 85 miles per hour
ef5 tornadoes are the strongest with the
wind speeds exceeding 200 miles per hour
one of the strongest tornadoes recorded
occurred in Oklahoma City Oklahoma
in 1999 born from a supercell
thunderstorm the ef5 tornado had wind
speeds of over 300 miles per hour it
resulted in 36 fatalities injured nearly
600 and caused about 1 billion dollars
in damages while tornadoes cannot be
prevented measures are being taken to
protect communities meteorologists
closely monitor storm fronts and
high-risk areas and try to forecast
possible tornadic events in doing so
they help mitigate damages to
neighborhoods and save countless lives
even in the face of one of nature's most
formidable
[Music]